ARTUR OLIVEIRA: All right.
Good afternoon, everyone.
Thank you all very much for
coming down to the Talks event
today.
My name is art Artur Oliveira.
I'm one of the Chicago site
leads for Talks at Google
here in Chicago.
I'm very excited
about this talk today.
I am going to let John Michael
Schert do his own introduction
because I just
couldn't do it justice.
But what I'm especially
excited about today
is this is a great opportunity
to really interact with him.
We have a small room but
a really good audience.
So, you know, he's
going to get started.
He has tons of interesting
content to share with you
and talk with you about.
But by all means,
like, don't feel
shy about asking questions,
jumping in, commenting,
and all of that.
It's a really good opportunity
that we have today.
So without further ado,
I'm going to turn it over
to John Michael.
JOHN MICHAEL SCHERT: Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
Oh, applause.
They're applauding already.
I've done nothing.
But thank you.
So I do have two first
names, John and Michael.
My mom gave me
that lifelong task.
I grew up in South Georgia.
And like most warm-blooded
American boys,
I started doing "The
Nutcracker" at the age of 6,
which led to, like, a
pretty interesting life.
So I've been a ballet dancer
now since 6 years old.
I've professionally been a
ballet dancer for 16 years.
According to Malcolm
Gladwell, I am an expert.
I have put in my 45,000 hours.
I have done, by
my last estimate,
over 300,000 plies,
which is just this
over and over and over again.
So ballet, like most any other
form, is highly rigorous.
You can compare it to
any other athletic sport.
You can compare it,
though, to learning
any skill, whether it's
a language, coding, most
anything.
We spend hundreds of thousands
of hours figuring out
the difference
between this and this.
That took about 10,000 hours
just to get that right.
So like most rigorous
forms, when you're young,
you're really just focusing
on the form itself.
It's a derivative
process, right?
Like, you're being given this
knowledge by your teachers.
And they're saying, you
need to do it this way.
And if you don't,
you don't measure up.
You're not good enough.
And so you're always
trying to find this more
extrinsically-- a
way you're filtering
this extrinsic information.
It takes a long time
before you start
to get that intrinsic
of, like, do you
know the difference
between this and this?
It takes a long time before
you can really feel it.
We do repetition.
We're doing the same thing
over and over and over and over
again.
So I moved away from home
at 14 to go to a boarding
school for ballet.
At 18 I moved to New York and
joined American Ballet Theatre,
which is considered--
it's like joining Google.
It's one of the top.
It's one of the top five
ballet companies in the world
for classical ballet.
It is a very, I would say,
quantitative ballet company.
Again, more is more.
You can measure who is better.
Five pirouettes is
better than four.
The way a foot
looks-- my parents
gave me good
genetics for ballet.
So my feet do what
they're supposed to do.
My proportions are right.
In some ways, I
didn't have to work
as hard as some of
my peers because I
had a lot of aptitude.
The way a foot looks,
the way a leg works,
how high your leg goes--
those are all ways that you're
evaluated and measured.
ABT, American Ballet Theatre,
is a very hierarchical system.
So I went to the summer
program at the age of 16.
And I met a group of
colleagues-- my cohort.
We all joined the same day.
And to this day, still one of
my favorite people in the world
is my good friend
Misty Copeland.
So we all joined the
same day, age 15.
At age 18, we all became
members of the Studio Company,
which is like the young bucks.
Then we became trainees.
Then we became apprentices.
Then we became corps
de ballet members.
And then she became a soloist.
And now she's a principal dancer
and the face of Under Armour.
The way you get
promoted was very much
based on how do you measure up.
So again, I'm going
to call this the form.
You had to excel at the form.
You had to excel at how
you processed and applied
extrinsic information.
You had to think quantitatively.
You had to understand the
objective nature of ballet,
more than the subjective.
Most people think
dancers are artists.
Most dancers aren't artists.
They're technicians.
They're very good at
applying all this information
and doing it brilliantly.
That wasn't enough for me.
So after only a
couple years at ABT,
I left to join a company that
was starting in New York called
Cedar Lake Contemporary Ballet.
It was well known because it
was-- most dance companies are
nonprofit.
So they're funded by
a variety of sources.
This was funded by one woman.
Her name's Nancy Walton Laurie.
She's a Walmart heiress.
I remember, on
the first day, she
walked in with her floor-length
purple mink coat and said,
I own a baseball team.
I own a hockey team.
I own championship
horses, and I own you.
I was only there
for three months.
But I met a man, Alonzo
King, who became really sort
of my mentor, a guru, almost.
So I moved to San Francisco
and tutored-- well,
I was in the company.
But really, I was a
mentee to this man.
So Alonzo was the
first one to teach me
the balance of what I'm going to
talk about today-- the balance
of the creative process.
So the creative
process is not just
all being in the right
brain all the time
and being in this
incredible gaseous state.
Has anyone read
Steven Johnson's,
"Where Good Ideas Come From"?
He talks about gaseous states.
They don't have as much form.
A great idea and
information can come.
It can flow a little
easier, compared
to, like, a solid-state
environment, which
was where I was coming from,
American Ballet Theatre.
I'm going to give the analogy
of two feet firmly planted.
That was ABT, like,
very much grounded.
A gaseous state, of course, is
just like everything's moving.
Everything's formless.
It's all about the feeling,
where ABT was all about
the form-- so form and feeling.
Gaseous states are much more,
like, intrinsically motivated.
What are you thinking?
How does this make you feel?
Where are you going
to go with it?
Most people think artists are
constantly just in this state,
right, where again, a
form-based, quantitative system
is much more, what
can you measure,
and what is being told to you,
and how are you replicating it?
Alonzo was the first
one to really teach me
the creative process
is how you find
this inner dialogue of form and
feeling, objective perspective,
subjective understanding.
How are you listening
while telling?
How are you doing
the choreography
and doing it with
great articulation
and great, like,
acumen and skill,
using all that ability
that you've been working on
for all those years to
make sure your thumb's not
like that but like that?
But how are you, in
the act of telling--
like, I'm going to do the step
for you-- how are you also
having a state of
reciprocal listening,
where you're opening
yourself up to possibility?
So you're not improvving.
You're not making
these steps up.
But it feels alive.
It feels spontaneous.
It feels real in this moment.
Alonzo would always say, I
don't want to see the steps.
I want to see the ideas, right?
So he's like, I don't
want to go on stage
and just see you
doing arithmetic.
Then the arm does this, and
then you do that, where at ABT,
that's what they valued.
No, your arm should
be here, not here.
You know, it's all about
placement, specificity.
But Alonzo would
say, I'm just going
to assume that you're
a genius, right?
Like, he's like, why should
I spend our time together
working on that?
That's your job.
That's what you've been spending
your whole life working on.
Why should we work
on that together?
I want to work on the ideas.
So one way that I think of this
is in a transactional system,
it's like, here's
where you need to be.
And this is how you measure up.
And then you match it, right?
And you find the
right frequency.
Alonzo, for me, was saying,
here's where I want you to be.
And you have to match it.
Within that has to be
a sustainable rise.
The form-- this
axis-- has to still
be based in the form
and the technique
and the data and
the information.
But how you get
to that rise equal
parts the intrinsic,
the subjective,
and what you're
bringing to the step.
So I'm going to say
the same thing to you
today that Alonzo said to me.
I'm just going to assume that
you all are genius, right?
You're here.
You work for this company.
You're very good at what you do.
So the gist of today's
talk, "The Utility
of the Creative
Process," is not just
how are you exercising
mastery in terms
of how you execute or implement
or even continue growing,
but how are you tapping into
that next level of what's
possible?
So I always like to joke that
creativity is 2/3 reality,
1/3 possibility, right?
Now, if you're in
this gaseous state,
it's like 3/3 possibility.
But if you're over here in the
solid state, it's 3/3 reality.
You need to be in a
fluid, agile state.
Again, to quote Steven
Johnson, "fluid systems."
The way I think of it is one
foot planted in the ground.
This is the technique, your
training, your knowledge,
your inheritance, tradition,
assets, resources-- everything
that you can measure.
But with this other
foot, you want
to be constantly
challenging yourself
to be finding and seeking,
going into the unknown, right?
So the Venn diagram of, like,
the known and the unknown,
it's that thin layer of overlap.
That's where possibility lies.
That's where, quote,
unquote, "innovation lies."
I mean, and what's innovation?
It's just creativity
monetized, right?
So how do you tap
into that unknown
and then bring it
back to the known?
How are you challenging
yourself to be
reaching out and gathering
this data, this information?
Alonzo would always say
that it's just information.
Without judgment, just
see it as possibility.
Without bias, allow
it to come in.
The beauty is the known-- the
portion that is the known--
continues to grow
throughout your life.
It continues to expand.
The unknown is infinite.
What you don't know or what
we collectively don't know
is infinite.
So how do you train yourself
with still a grounding
and a sense of purpose?
Be tapping into
that-- that adjacent
possible-- what could be.
I call that the
creative process.
So the creative process
is not one or the other.
It's both in equal measure.
There's a famous psychologist
from the University Chicago,
Mihaly Csikszentmihalyi.
He wrote the book "Flow."
He wrote the book "Creativity."
So how do you find
that flow state?
He thought about it
and talks about it
as sort of another XY axis.
On this axis is the given
demands of a situation--
how you have to measure up.
And on this axis is your
proclivity or ability
or aptitude for that
given situation.
So if the demands are very
high, and your ability is low,
you probably have
anxiety, right?
If your ability is very high,
and the demands are low,
you probably have apathy.
But how are you in a
given moment, like,
arriving at that
optimal flow state?
So again, a choreographer,
in the dance world,
gives you the steps,
gives you sometimes
the meaning, the musicality.
They create the structure.
That's the data-- the
extrinsic, the quantitative.
You can't change that.
You can't violate it.
And like Alonzo would say, I
don't want to see the steps.
I want to see the ideas.
What are you going
to do with it?
What you do with it,
that's art-making.
It's not just how well
you went out on stage
and did those steps.
It's how you made them prescient
and available and spontaneous
in this moment.
So I now work at the
University of Chicago
with the Booth
School of Business.
I'm the first Visiting
Artist & Social Entrepreneur.
It's a bunch of words, right?
Like, it takes me a
while to say them.
We're making this up as we go.
The cool thing is University
of Chicago Booth School
of Business is not necessarily
known for being the most
fluid-state environment.
They are known for being the
most conservative business
school in the world, where free
market capitalism was invented.
But even within that
very, in some ways,
solid-state environment, there
are some brilliant teachers
and educators,
one in particular,
a man named Harry Davis,
who's been there 53 years.
And he's been teaching the
impact of the arts on business
for longer than I've been alive.
And so we met.
And in one meeting,
he said, what would it
look like if you
came and started
playing in this environment?
So I've been there two
and a half years now.
I question a lot of times, like,
why did I make this decision?
Why did I choose to go into
this environment in which we
don't really speak the
same language, right?
And kind of in hindsight,
two and a half years in,
it's understanding how these
ideas I knew as an artist
and as a dancer-- these
ideas of creative process
can be translated,
can become applicable
in different scenarios.
I'm skipping over a
crucial element, which is I
also cofounded and ran as the
executive director for a decade
my own dance company.
So for a decade, I was
dancing while having to bring
in millions of dollars a year.
I was the booking agent.
I managed the
board of directors.
I managed the staff.
I, yeah, philanthropically was
raising money while dancing.
And it was during that time
I left Alonzo's tutelage,
this man that was
incredibly brilliant
and had really allowed
me to tap into this--
and we'll say more in it
throughout our conversation--
this idea of creative process.
And for the first time,
I was in a scenario
where I was the
executive director.
I was pretty young-- early 20s.
I didn't really know
what I was doing.
But I had to begin to learn how
to apply these same concepts.
How do you go about
raising $2 million a year?
I sat with people,
and they said, well,
you break it into buckets.
How much are you going to
raise from individuals,
from foundations, from
government, from corporations?
How many from special events?
How much is fee for
services for touring?
How much is education?
You break it into the buckets.
And you make this budget at
the beginning of the year.
And your board of directors--
you know, approved.
Here's your budget.
And then I remember the first
year, I was like, oh, crap.
Like, how do I do this?
How do I suddenly
conjure up this money?
So how do you deal
with the unknown?
Another way of
saying it is risk.
How do you deal with risk?
Most systems try to minimize
risk to such a degree
that we strategize
before the process.
Before you implement,
you've strategized
exactly how this will play out.
And you've tried to minimize
the risk to the degree you could
that when you
implement everything
is going to follow a
pretty set system, right?
Being an artist and
working with Alonzo--
by doing that, if
I went out on stage
and just only did
the steps, right,
you've robbed yourself
of all that input.
You've robbed yourself
of all that possibility.
If you're only working in
the known in a derivative
system that's been
laid out, you're
not allowing yourself to be
able to bring in and channel
all this other information.
I love to go back and
spend time with Alonzo.
A couple months ago, I was
in the studio observing.
And the choreography
was this female dancer.
Beautiful-- she's 6
foot, 1, long limbs.
The choreography was that
she had to walk forward
and then just
stand for a moment.
And then at the
right moment, she
had to launch into this, like,
very dramatic, big solo-- huge,
expansive.
And it was all
about power and how
you're exercising
all these faculties
and a lot of articulation.
But she walked forward, and she
was like a horse at the gate,
just ready to go.
And then she started.
And Alonzo stopped, and he
said, you have to come forward.
And you have to have a moment
where you let it all go.
In Zen Buddhism, they
call that beginner's mind.
Like, you can't know
what you're about to do.
You almost have to
choose to not know
so that you can be
present, so that you
can allow what's about
to happen to work on you
as much as you're
about to work on it.
So a second ago when I
said, listening and telling,
you can't just get
out there and tell.
Like, I'm showing
you all these steps.
And here's what it is.
Because the human condition is
such that in any given moment,
you don't know most of
what's going to happen.
And if you're not
making yourself
available to that
kind of unknown--
if you're not listening,
you're robbing yourself
of what's possible.
So right now I'm sitting here
telling things towards you.
I'm saying a bunch of words.
This is actually very
much a conversation.
Maybe because I am a ballet
dancer, I know who's into it.
I know who's
checking their phone.
I know who's taking notes and
who's actually doing email.
I can tell, like,
when you lean in when
I say something
that was of import
and when you like
drift off again.
And this is a dialogue.
And so I'm exercising
my own creative process
at this moment of,
like, I don't know
what I'm going to say to you.
I have a grab bag of quotes
and stories and pieces of data
that I could tell you.
But for this to be really
a moment that we're
sharing, like, a present
moment where we're really,
like, hopefully arriving at
something together and not just
this transaction where I'm
sending out information,
and then you're absorbing
it and hopefully
processing-- if this is really
going to be something more
aspirational, and we're
building something
in this collective,
collaborative moment,
I have to be present.
Presence is another
way of talking
about the creative process.
It's that balance
of all these things.
You can't just come
in and know what
you're going to say and say it.
It has to be a relationship
that we're having right now.
So in my current line
of work, I consult
for hedge funds and companies
and civic governments.
I coach MBAs.
I coach entrepreneurs.
I teach workshops and
classes on similar themes,
similar things I'm
saying to you today.
But a lot of them have
real-world applications.
So I work with teams, companies
to help them identify,
what is your creative process.
And what's interesting
is people always
think I'm going to show up
and give them 10-step lists.
Do these 10 things, and
you, too, can be creative.
I work with a man at the
University of Chicago
who runs the Center
for Wisdom Research.
And he said something
really fascinating.
He said, there's no such
thing as a wise person.
There's only wise choices.
So I think that applies.
There's no such thing
as a creative person.
There's only creative choices.
So creativity is like,
yeah, maybe if you're,
in one given day, you made
majority creative choices, you
might be a creative person for
that day-- maybe in a year,
like, if you are exercising
creative choice-making.
But below that level of
creative choice-making
is what I'm calling
this creative process.
It's that internal
balance of how
you're seeing a given situation,
being adaptable, responding
to it, and then arriving at
that-- again, 2/3 reality,
1/3 possibility--
how are you arriving
at that what's possible?
That's what creative
choice-making is.
It's not the derivative system.
It's not the staid, here's what
we've already have figured out,
just implement system.
It's here's what I know, and
here's what could happen.
So how are you making
creative choices?
How are you exercising
that creative process
to arrive at this balance?
It's not an additive
process, I've found.
Like Alonzo said, you
have to walk forward,
and you actually have to let go.
There's another
expression in Zen Buddhism
that the water is going to flow.
Like, if a stream or a
river is already flowing,
it's going to flow.
It's can you remove
more and more rocks
to allow it to flow even more--
to flow even more smoothly?
So the creative process,
as I think about it
when I consult for
these companies,
is really a reductive process.
What are you doing
that's preventing you
from kind of accessing
all that information?
What are your internal biases?
What are the rules or
obligations or constraints
that you think you
have to live by?
What are the behaviors or
ways that you show up that you
think are expected of you?
Creativity is also
just the ability
to see one thing from
multiple perspectives
and to exercise empathy
to see the bigger picture
and then arrive at a creative
choice, which might be,
we're going to take all that
information-- all that data--
and then we're
going to arrive at,
but what is the most
interesting or new or unexpected
way to now display this hand
moving forward into the world?
It's usually a reductive
process in the sense
that the information's
already there.
Sometimes you're
just not seeing it.
Or sometimes you're not
letting yourself believe
that that could be the answer.
Or sometimes you're just-- we
all are getting more caught up
in the form and what we can
be measured against rather
than that next thing that is
amorphous and not fully formed
and shaped yet.
That's one of the
biggest hindrances
I see when I consult for more
solid-state organizations,
corporations, civic governments.
I remember there
was a company here
in Chicago that had
me come in to help
them be more innovative.
And they said, well, we
tried to be innovative.
We created this
whole system where
people would be incentivized.
And they'd get paid extra
if they were innovative
and if they came up with new
ideas and new potentials.
And he said, it
failed miserably.
Nobody was willing to take risk.
No one was willing
to go there because
in the end, a lot of
times, we as humans
will do the thing we know we
can be measured on, right?
We do the thing.
We invest the time, the
resources, the energy
as long as we know that
at the end what we did
is worthwhile because it
measures up to certain existing
standards.
It's very hard to move beyond
the standards and step out.
And with this analogy
of the one foot planted
and the other foot
searching, it's
not that you just suddenly,
like, go into a freefall.
It's that you're challenging
yourself to kind of always
be on that space
in between, right?
The space in between this
action and this action--
there's so much information
right there in between.
I was getting my foot
X-rayed recently.
And the doctor said, you
have really good cartilage.
I said, how can you tell?
Because on the X-ray,
it's just black and white.
He said, there was a lot of
space in between the bones.
I was like, oh, that's
what I'm getting at here.
The creative process is this,
like, piece of cartilage.
It's that buffer.
In the brain, they call
it the corpus callosum,
the webbing that's connecting
the right and left sides
of the brain.
For decades or
even a century now,
we knew about the
corpus callosum.
And neuroscientists
and doctors didn't
think it had any purpose because
it didn't light up in the way
that other parts
of the brain were.
So they actually would sever it
in certain types of patients.
People with
epilepsy-- they found
if they severed the
corpus callosum,
the seizures would be less.
But what started to
happen was people
began to have-- they were
robbed of certain forms
of emotional reasoning.
Their EQ was diminished.
Their IQ stayed intact.
But other ways of
perceiving diminished.
So this webbing--
this space in between,
where you don't really know
what it is and where it goes.
So this is the thing with
a lot of these companies.
How do you invest
time, resources, energy
in the unknown?
How do you set aside-- and
obviously, here at Google,
there are practices and
methods for which Google
has done that historically.
How do you set aside--
what is it now?
Is it 20% time still?
I always forget.
How do you incentivize
people having unformed time?
How do you give
people permission
to delve into that space?
How do you give
people permission
to not be productive?
Our analytic mine operates a
lot of times off of alpha waves.
And it's all about the action
steps, the action skills.
The insightful mind is a
different part of your brain
that operates a lot of
time off of gamma waves.
It can only be active when
the alpha mind, alpha waves--
the analytic mind-- is at rest.
So that's why you always
get those quotes of,
it came to them in the
shower, or it came to them
while they were
going for a walk.
It's because the moment
you take your mind off
of this-- the action, the step,
the thought-- your unconscious
keeps working on it.
And then that insight pops up.
So how do you train-- I think,
let's start chatting now.
How do you train your mind to
practice insightful thinking
versus analytic thinking?
How do you train your mind to
step into the unknown, still
grounded in the known,
and be able to bring
that information back?
How do you exercise your own
personal creative process?
And what I do for a living
is I help individuals
think about that.
And then I help
them think about how
we do it as a team,
and as an organization,
and all the layers.
But I find usually people
eradicate the creative process
very quickly because
they keep reverting back
to what can be measured and what
can be stated unequivocally.
So I think we're-- yeah.
I will pose that as a question.
How do you practice
the creative process?
You can answer.
Anyone can answer.
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: By
introducing deadlines.
By giving myself false deadlines
that I have to stick to.
Usually, I buy or
invest [INAUDIBLE].
JOHN MICHAEL SCHERT: False
deadlines-- I like that.
Yeah.
Anyone else?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I think
for me, it came down
to the permission thing.
So I'll, like, set time in my
calendar actually to, like,
set aside for that sort
of thinking to actually
explicitly give yourself
permission to do it.
So you actually feel like
you're still time-managed.
So you're going to
get the things done
you need to get done.
And you don't feel as bad
allotting that time to just
[INAUDIBLE].
JOHN MICHAEL SCHERT:
Yeah, I love that.
I do both those things, as well.
Every day, for me, I have
an hour block on my calendar
that's just, like, unknown time.
I put it there sometimes
months in advance
so I don't violate it later.
And I also put these arbitrary
deadlines on my calendar.
I'm a very visual person, so
my calendar is, like, God.
What else?
AUDIENCE: I think when you
think about creativity,
about something
that as kids we're
always-- it's something
we just naturally do.
And as we grow older
[INAUDIBLE] school or whatever,
we lose that habit.
And I think one of the
stories that I've heard
is that, for those people
that have kids, right,
they bring this crazy drawing.
And as a parent,
you're not going
to be, like, that's the ugliest
house I've ever seen, right?
Quite the opposite.
You tell kids, that's
the most beautiful house
I've seen in my entire life.
That's, like, that
creativity that once you
get into the real
world, you lose
the ability to be able to
do that because, I mean,
you talk about risk, right,
that if it's not done right,
then I shouldn't do it.
So for me, it's like where
I identify with, like,
what I'm passionate about
and carving time to do that,
whether it's reading or
writing or something that sort
of strikes [INAUDIBLE].
JOHN MICHAEL SCHERT: Yeah.
I heard a story recently.
A teacher said, what
are you drawing, Susie?
And she's like, I'm
drawing a picture of God.
She's like, honey, no one
knows what God looks like.
She's like, they're about to.
It's the idea that,
like, my perspective
is equal or valuable and giving
yourself permission for it.
Yeah, you had your hand up.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
I heard this expression
once-- interesting input
makes for interesting output.
So I want to try and get access
kind of the insightful mind.
Give myself permission
just to [INAUDIBLE]
input that inspires me.
JOHN MICHAEL SCHERT: Yeah.
Permission-giving is really hard
sometimes to give to ourselves
because, again, we can
default back to all the things
that we know we have
to do or should do.
I call them the coulds
and the shoulds.
Like, we know what
we should go do.
And we know what we
could go do because we
have the aptitude or the
ability or the opportunity.
It's often hard to give
equal weight to the want.
Like, what do I want to go do?
And oftentimes, the
best information
comes from, like, the
intrinsically motivated
or carving out the time to
give yourself permission
to just put food in your head.
AUDIENCE: Can you talk a
little bit more about that?
Like, both as a person, how do
you give yourself permission?
But then maybe your role
as a consultant [INAUDIBLE]
other companies, how do you
go up to an organization
that's done things for the past
10 years, and it's worked well
and ask them to give permission
to try something new?
Like, what's that
first step look like?
JOHN MICHAEL SCHERT:
Well, I mean,
sometimes it's good
just to frame it as in,
let's agree on some
universal truths.
Like, change is constant.
So any system has already become
antiquated with every day,
right?
So you have to be generating
new potential ways of seeing.
It's not about new
ways of implementing.
But it is definitely
new ways of, like,
are you staying always
aware that you're absorbing
more and more information?
Now, analytics is a
great way to do it.
Like, this balance
of form and feeling--
like, the quant side
is super important
because it's how we're
going and gathering
information and bringing it in.
But then again, what do
you do with that data?
How do you process it?
So a lot of companies will
say, oh, our system is working.
But we all know if you're not
always tapping in and getting
into that adjacent possible--
if you're not always
living on that precipice
that we keep talking about,
you will quickly be antiquated.
Like, that's just
going to happen.
So usually, I can frame
it in that way for them.
And they're like, oh yeah, we
can accept that as a truth.
And then the next
step is getting
them to realize how they're
already giving themselves
permission to make
creative choices,
or how they're already doing it.
So how can I help them
reinforce that that's
a really valid thing?
But usually, it falls in that,
again, that space in between.
It's not like a system
they have in place.
Like, you work for one
of the few companies
in the world that have systems
for those sorts of things.
Most companies don't.
So getting them to acknowledge--
it's always the, like,
amazing-to-have-it skill, but
no one knows how to teach it.
I think you can teach
all those things.
You can train them.
Those are skills
that you can work on.
So it's-- and I hate the
expression "soft skills"
because usually it's not hard.
It's not real.
But it usually lies more in
that qualitative soft side.
So I usually get them to think
about how they're already
doing it.
Are the individuals
in their midst
that are already doing it?
I try to help champion.
I mean, I'm completely-- it's
a bit subversive, but it's not.
Like, I think we should be
elevating creative thinkers
to be leaders-- civically
and corporations.
I think every board of directors
should have an artist sitting
at the table, someone
that really holds
the space for creative
process because you already
have at the table 10 dudes
who speak money and finance.
And you've got people
that speak legalities.
And you have scientists
and engineers.
And you have people that deal
in liability and insurance.
But you don't always
carve out a space
for that person who really
practices a creative process
at a very heightened level.
So I try to find the people
that are already doing it,
especially the ones that are
already in senior positions
and help sort of, like,
fortify that what they've done
is super worthwhile.
A lot of times,
everyone knows it.
But they haven't really,
like, built a system around it
or, like, incentivized it in a
way that allows others to feel
they, too, can be that way.
We always fall back on it.
Like, in a law firm
that I was working with,
one senior partner was,
like, incredibly creative.
And everyone, like, praised him.
He was the Steve Jobs of law.
Somehow, he broke all the rules.
And he went and did all
these things the way
no one had ever done it before.
But when you talked to
the junior associates
and whatnot, why don't
you act more like him?
Well, I can't because
he's a senior partner.
And he has all these
permissions I don't have,
and he can do
things in this way.
People think that
like, you chew the fat.
You do the work, and then you
get to a level of a status.
And then you can start to
exercise creative process.
I think it's more like a
well-marbled piece of meat.
Like, you have to be practicing
this creative process.
The best piece of
the cut of meat
has, like, the fat and
the meat all together.
It's more flavorful.
It's more valuable.
But we think, oh,
we're just going
to do this very, like,
left-brained way of doing
things.
And then we can get to that.
And when I mentor MBAs
and whatnot, and I say,
if you don't start
practicing that skill now,
it won't be available
to you at 45.
So junior associates think,
I don't have that permission.
And so I say, well,
I've been hired
to come here to tell you do.
So it's permission-giving.
But it's permission-giving
over and over and over again.
And it's helping them understand
all the ways they're not
giving themselves permission.
Why did they stop
at that moment?
And it's usually,
again, because they
have some idea that
someone else is going
to tell them they can't do it.
And that's almost
never the case.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: What are some of the
things that have been really,
kind of stood out
to you when working
with these more
traditional, like,
financial companies,
for example,
of when you have spotted
creativity in leadership?
What does that look like?
Like, I guess,
what's a good example
of how the
corporation can, like,
weave in that
creativity really well
in the context of a
nontraditionally creative
company?
JOHN MICHAEL SCHERT: Yeah.
On a human level, it's
usually the person
that's listening the
most and practicing
epistemic humility, which
is a term meaning, like,
choosing to be humble.
It's the person that's choosing
to practice beginner's mind
and not know.
They might be the most
senior brilliant person.
So what's the difference
between a smart choice
and a wise choice and
a creative choice?
This is what one of my
colleagues at the University
of Chicago works on.
Like, so a smart
choice is what we all
are trained to do in
our education system.
Like, it's more analytic.
It's more, like, you
add up these things,
and you arrive at the solution.
I've already talked a bit about
creative choice-making, which
is, like, that overlap
of the Venn diagram
and the possibility.
And if you could tap into
that, what's possible?
What's more of a
creative choice?
Because you're allowing yourself
to open up to the unknown.
Wise choice-making--
and everyone
knows Maslow's
hierarchy of needs.
At some point you've
seen that-- that pyramid.
Wise choice-making
is the top pinnacle--
helping others unlock
their full potential.
Processiality--
another key component
of wise choice-making--
is epistemic humility,
which is the ability
to, like, not
exercise ego in
choice-making and also
to be available to others.
You know, Warren Buffett says, I
spend most of my time thinking,
just sitting there.
It's not measurable.
Now, of course, he has these
outputs that are amazing.
So we're all like, well,
let's all act more like Warren
Buffett.
But why do more people
not just spend time
letting their unconscious
mind be at play?
So when I find it in
these companies, again,
and someone at a high
level is practicing
more what I would call
wise choice-making, which
has built into it smart
choice-making, which
is level five of Maslow's, and
creative choice-making, which
I would say is level seven
of Maslow's, like-- but,
again, it's more of an
allowing, a permission-giving
they give to themselves.
And then the
companies-- even, like,
solid-state, traditional
companies-- that
seem to do it well,
they don't always
presuppose that their status,
their power, their market share
is permanent.
And they are very
open to possibility.
They don't rule out
ideas right away.
They don't have as much judgment
about when an idea comes up,
they give it weight.
They give it time--
within reason--
because this is where
you start to then run
into time management and
systems management and all
those other things.
But one of the hedge funds I
work with, a brilliant man--
it's actually a mutual fund.
He said, I never
sought to make money.
I never sought growth.
And now he's a billionaire.
But he said, I just wanted
to do cool things that
were interesting to me.
So there's a lot of
behavioral science now
that shows if you seek the
reward-- the extrinsic reward--
you rob yourself of the
intrinsic creative process.
If you seek the intrinsic
creative process,
you're, A, more
self-fulfilled and happy.
And then if you still get
the reward, it's a bonus.
But we set up a
lot of our systems
to be measuring what's
the outcome going to be.
I'm just going to
work towards that.
And they've robbed
themselves of the process.
Jess, you had something.
AUDIENCE: I was just
[INAUDIBLE] to your [INAUDIBLE]
expectations and the
feeling sometimes
that hinders me
creatively when I
set either unrealistic or
somehow not [INAUDIBLE] or not
realistic expectations.
And then I feel like I didn't
deliver, which creates,
like, something [INAUDIBLE].
JOHN MICHAEL SCHERT: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So I think
I've gotten better at it.
And it's really hard to create
realistic expectations that
are still, like, impactful.
JOHN MICHAEL SCHERT: Yeah.
I think it's people
are really good again,
at naming the coulds
and the shoulds,
like what they should do
and what they could do.
And then they often make
that their entire expectation
setting.
And so how do you factor
in from the onset--
from the beginning, the outset--
also the intrinsic motivation?
I find that we often sell our--
we often set up the expectation
with our boss,
with our employer,
with ourself, or
with others that's
all based on others'
expectations of you
and not your
expectations of yourself.
It's kind of a pat answer.
But I'll say more later
because I know you.
And we can talk more.
But I think we're coming
up on end of time.
Does anyone have
one more question?
And if not, I just want to
say, thanks for hanging out
for an hour or so.
And of course, it's very
exciting what Google does.
And that's why I was
excited to come and chat
with you all today
because I know
I'm talking-- preaching to the
choir, in a lot of respects.
But it's always
fascinating to come
into different environments and
hear what you're thinking on.
So I'd love to continue the
dialogue with any of you
if you want to, like, chat now.
Or just email and chat later.
But thanks so much.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]